It's a classic David and Goliath situation. Younger sister and older sister. In this case, it's a big age gap. The older sister's 12. That's Kennedy. The younger sister's just 5. That's Zadie. And their mom, who was an only child, found their fighting to be kind of overwhelming.
这是一个典型的大卫与歌利亚的故事。妹妹和姐姐。在这种情况下，年龄差距很大。姐姐肯尼迪12岁，妹妹扎迪才5岁。她们的母亲是独生女，发现两个女儿打架让她感到难以应付。
They bicker constantly. They just fight and are at each other.
她们一直在吵嘴。她们总是打架，针锋相对。
[CRYING]
[哭泣声]
Z.
Z。
[CRYING]
[哭泣声]
It's not physical, but it's a constant natter. It's a constant back-and-forth.
虽然不是肢体冲突，但总是喋喋不休。一直没完没了地争吵。
So, two months ago, their mom, Lisa, came up with an idea, a way to change things between the two girls. She and I talked about it back then. You're going to notice in this  recording that I have a pretty bad cold when we had this conversation.
所以，两个月前，她们的妈妈莉萨想到了一个主意，一种改变两个女孩之间关系的方法。那时我和她聊过这个。你会注意到在这段录音中，我们交谈时我得了很重的感冒。
At the time, Lisa described for me the girls' history together.
当时，莉萨向我讲述了这两个女孩的过往。
Once Zadie realized, when she was about two, that Kennedy wasn't going to play with her, she would do things like pinch her. She would scratch her. She would bite her.
当扎迪大约两岁，意识到肯尼迪不会跟她玩时，她就会做出掐她、抓她、咬她之类的事情。
She wants her attention.
她想要姐姐的关注。
Notice me, you know. I want to adore you. Let me.
“注意到我吧，你知道的。我想喜欢你。让我喜欢你吧。”
Yeah. I have this relationship with my wife. We'll be sitting on the couch, and she'll hit me.
是的。我和我妻子也有这种关系。我们会坐在沙发上，然后她会打我。
Play with me.
“跟我玩。”
Exactly. She'll literally say, pay attention to me.
没错。她会直白地说，关注我。
I like you.
“我喜欢你。”
Zadie, get up. Get off of Kennedy.
扎迪，起来。从肯尼迪身上下来。
I like her.
“我喜欢她。”
Zadie, please get off.
扎迪，请下来。
I like her.
“我喜欢她。”
Mute that for a second?
能暂停一下吗？
So as Zadie got older, Kennedy now sees her as this little kid who can't really play, who is a nuisance, who can pick out what's going to bug Kennedy and do it.
随着扎迪长大，肯尼迪现在把她看作一个根本没法一起玩的小屁孩，一个讨人厌的麻烦精，而且她总能挑出肯尼迪最烦的事去做。
And what was the low point of all this? When did you look around you and just think, What am I doing as a parent?
那么这一切的最低谷是什么？你什么时候环顾四周，心想，我作为父母到底在干什么？
I guess this summer, when they were both home from school and fighting all the time. And I just realized, it's not changing. And if it doesn't change now, it's not going to change. Because they're both getting-- I think Zadie's now getting old enough to form this opinion of her sister. And I thought, I don't want that opinion to be that they're not allies. I don't want it to be that they're not friends. Now's the time to do something.
我想是今年夏天，她们都放假在家，一直吵个不停。我突然意识到，这种情况不会改变。如果现在不改变，以后也不会改变了。因为她们都在长大——我想扎迪现在已经大到可以对姐姐形成这种看法了。我想，我不希望她们认为彼此不是盟友。我不希望她们不是朋友。现在是采取行动的时候了。
And so what's your plan?
那你的计划是什么？
What we're going to do is this little experiment called the Kill Her With Kindness Experiment. I gave it a name.
我们要做的就是一个叫“用仁慈杀死她实验”的小实验。我给它取了个名字。
So are you some sort of behavioral psychologist or something?
所以你是什么行为心理学家之类的吗？
Oh, God, no. No, I just went on the internet to junior high science experiments and got a whole bunch of stuff and presented it to Ken.
噢，天哪，不。不，我只是上网找了些初中科学实验，弄了一大堆东西，然后呈献给肯尼迪。
Whoa, whoa, whoa. OK, you have the two people who are most precious to you in this world, and you have a problem, and the thought that occurs to you is not, I'm going to seek professional help. I'm going to go to a family counselor. No, what you did is that you went onto the internet and found experiments at a junior high school, not even at the high school level?
哇，等等。好吧，你拥有这世界上对你最宝贵的两个人，你遇到了问题，而你脑海里冒出的想法不是，“我要去寻求专业帮助，我要去找家庭咨询师”。不，你做的是上网找初中生的实验，甚至不是高中水平的？
No. OK, that's the end. That's not where I started. I read all the books, and I talked to all my friends.
不。好吧，那是结局。那不是我开始的地方。我读了所有的书，也和所有的朋友聊过。
When David is facing off against Goliath, nothing normal is going to work. Normal is just going to keep you stuck. If you've got a situation where one side is super-powerful, one side is very weak, normal is just status quo. Nothing is going to change. Your only chance is grand, extraordinary measures. A junior high school experiment? That is about as good as a slingshot. And today on our program, we're going to bring you three stories of people trying extraordinary things to balance the scales between David and Goliath.
当大卫面对歌利亚时，任何常规方法都不会奏效。常规只会让你原地踏步。如果处于一方极其强大、一方极其弱小的局面，常规只会维持现状。什么都不会改变。你唯一的希望是采取宏大、非凡的措施。初中科学实验？那跟弹弓的效果差不多。今天在我们的节目中，我们将为您讲述三个关于人们试图采取非凡手段来平衡大卫与歌利亚之间力量对比的故事。
Act One is about a little girl and a big girl. Act Two is about a little country and a big country. Act Three is about some small-minded people and some very big-minded retail chains, and something about American commerce that happens all the time, everywhere, that no one has noticed is a national phenomenon except David Sedaris. Stay with us.
第一幕是关于一个小女孩和一个大女孩。第二幕是关于一个小国家和一个大国家。第三幕是关于一些心胸狭窄的人和一些极其大型的零售连锁店，以及某种经常发生在任何地方、每个人都习以为常但没人注意到这已成为全国性现象的美国商业行为，大卫·塞达里斯除外。请继续收听。
OK, so you remember where we are with Act One. You've got Zadie, you've got Kennedy, and their story. Their mom, two months ago, was explaining to me how she was going to try to solve one of the oldest struggles that humans have ever had, the struggle between big sibling and little sibling. Again, we've got a 12-year-old. We've got a 5-year-old. Two months ago, the mom, Lisa, went to the older girl, Kennedy, with a plan. And Kennedy is the kind of 12-year-old who loves reading, who loves science, who loves experiments. And Lisa explained the idea of this one to her.
好的，记得我们第一幕讲到哪了吗。你有扎迪，有肯尼迪，还有她们的故事。她们的母亲在两个月前向我解释她将如何尝试解决人类最古老的冲突之一：大孩子和小孩子之间的矛盾。再次强调，一个是12岁，一个是5岁。两个月前，母亲莉萨带着计划找到了姐姐肯尼迪。肯尼迪是那种喜欢阅读、热爱科学、喜欢实验的12岁女孩。莉萨向她解释了这个想法。
We're going to have a month-long experiment where Kennedy is actually really kind to Zadie and plays with her. And we're going to see if that chills Zadie out at all. We're going to see if that changes Zadie's behavior. So the whole thing, I guess, has been sold to Kennedy as behavior modification.
我们将进行为期一个月的实验，期间肯尼迪要对扎迪表现得非常友善并跟她玩。我们要看看这是否能让扎迪冷静下来。我们要看看这是否会改变扎迪的行为。所以这一切，我想，被作为行为矫正推销给了肯尼迪。
Wait, wait. Are those the words that you used with Kennedy?
等等，等等。你对肯尼迪用的是这些词吗？
I did. I told her it was a behavior modification experiment. Yeah. How I see it as a parent is, I want them actually to interact with each other. But that's not what I sold to Kennedy. I haven't really sold it to her as modifying her behavior at all. I sold it solely as modifying Zadie's behavior.
是的。我告诉她这是一个行为矫正实验。是的。作为父母，我是这样看的：我想要她们真正地互动。但那并不是我推销给肯尼迪的内容。我并没有把它包装成矫正她的行为。我把它完全包装成矫正扎迪的行为。
So this is going to cut Zadie down from irritating Kennedy, from being a pain to Kennedy, touching her stuff, going in her room when she doesn't want her to. If Kennedy's drawing on a piece of paper and Zadie comes by and will step on, like, that kind of behavior that Kennedy sees as an absolute pain. I've sold it to her as, Let's see if what Zadie actually wants is you to play with her and pay attention to her. So let's see if you doing that is going to stop all the negative behavior.
这样扎迪就不会再惹恼肯尼迪，不会再让肯尼迪感到痛苦，不会再乱动她的东西，也不会在肯尼迪不想让她进房间时硬闯。比如肯尼迪正在纸上画画，扎迪跑过来踩上一脚，这种肯尼迪视为绝对痛苦的行为。我向她推销的是：“让我们看看扎迪是不是真的只是想要你陪她玩、关注她。看看你这样做能不能停止她所有的负面行为。”
So what she's going to have to do is, after school, spend-- I say an hour. She says that's going to be too long, and Zadie's not going to want to play for an hour. But that's what I'm envisioning, an hour playing together.
所以她要做的就是，放学后，花——我说一小时。她说那太久了，扎迪不会想玩那么久的。但这正是我设想的，一起玩一个小时。
Every day.
每天。
Every day. I'm going to pay her, which is probably what she likes the best.
每天。我会付钱给她，这可能是她最喜欢的部分。
How much is she going to get?
她能得到多少钱？
She's going to get quite a bit. She upped it. She actually negotiated her price. I said $50 for the whole month. And she said, No way. It wasn't worth buying in for $50. So she's going to get $100. But she's got to actually do it. She's got to actually play with her sister.
她能得到不少。她还加价了。她实际上自己谈了价码。我说整个月50美元。她说，没门。50美元买不动她。所以她会得到100美元。但她必须真的去做。她必须真的跟她妹妹玩。
And they think my idea of what siblings-- how they interact is totally unrealistic.
他们觉得我对兄弟姐妹如何互动的设想太不现实了。
Because your ideal is based on?
因为你的理想是基于？
The Sound of Music. I mean, my ideal is that they get along, that they love each other, that they stand up for each other on the playground, that they--
《音乐之声》。我的理想是她们和睦相处，彼此相爱，在操场上互相保护，她们——
--sing together.
——一起唱歌。
--sing together. Which is so funny, because that has a lot to do, probably, with being an only child and always wanting a sister or a brother or just a sibling, another relationship. I was raised watching that movie over and over, and really having that sense of all these kids band together. But, of course, they band together-- like, those poor kids, they're traumatized. Their father's a tyrant. Of course they band together, right?
——一起唱歌。这太搞笑了，因为这很可能和我作为独生子女、总是渴望有个姐妹或兄弟、渴望另一种关系有关。我从小就是一遍遍看着那部电影长大的，真的有那种孩子们团结在一起的感觉。但当然，她们团结在一起是因为——那些可怜的孩子们，她们遭受了创伤，她们的父亲是个暴君。当然她们会团结起来，对吧？
And they're running from the Nazis.
而且她们还在躲避纳粹。
Exactly. Not till the end.
没错。直到最后。
[MUSIC - "THE LONELY GOATHERD" BY RODGERS AND HAMMERSTEIN]
[音乐 - 罗杰斯与汉默斯坦的《孤独的牧羊人》]
Have you shown The Sound of Music to the girls?
你给这两个女孩看过《音乐之声》吗？
Yes.
看过。
And do you say--
你会对她们说——
This is what you should do.
“这就是你们应该做的。”
You haven't.
你没这么说。
No. I've said things like, Just stop fighting and love each other. Though I have said that, and meant it. And I've said-- yeah. I mean, Kennedy says to me, Your idea is absolutely unrealistic.
没有。我说过诸如“别吵架，相亲相爱”之类的话。我确实说过，并且是真心的。而且我曾说——是的。我的意思是，肯尼迪对我说：“你的想法绝对不现实。”
Yeah. Yeah, you didn't have siblings. I mean, I think it's very, very possible that, because of the age difference-- you've got two kids, they're seven years apart. They're never going to be peers until they're adults some day. I just think it's possible that there's nothing that you can do.
是啊。是啊，你小时候没有兄弟姐妹。我的意思是，我觉得很有可能，因为年龄差异——两个孩子，差了七岁。在她们成年之前，她们永远不可能是平等的玩伴。我觉得可能你什么都做不了。
You're right. The thing is, I am not expecting them to interact as peers. But right now, it's the opposite of that. I think Kennedy actively dislikes her. She says it like that. She says it like, I really don't like this kid.
你说得对。问题是，我并不指望她们以同龄人的方式互动。但现在，情况恰恰相反。我觉得肯尼迪主动地讨厌她。她就是这么说的。她说得就像：“我真的不喜欢这个小孩。”
What do you think the chances are that this is going to succeed, if you just had to lay odds? 80% chance? 70% chance? 90% chance?
你觉得如果让你押注，这成功的几率有多少？80%？70%？90%？
I'm optimistic. I'd put it high. I put it at 80% that it's going to decrease the amount of fighting. Yes.
我很乐观。我会给高一点。我给80%，觉得它会减少打架的数量。是的。
I'm going to put this at 30%.
我给30%。
[GROANS].
[呻吟声]
So, Lisa LaBorde, many weeks have passed since our first conversation. And you have run your experiment. Did it work?
那么，莉萨·拉博德，距离我们第一次谈话已经过了许多周。你已经进行了实验。有效吗？
A qualified yes.
算是有条件的肯定吧。
Well, let's get right to results. Are your kids fighting less?
好吧，我们直接看结果。她们打架变少了吗？
By the end of the experiment, they were fighting less. By week four, less fighting.
实验结束时，她们打架变少了。到第四周，打架确实减少了。
You are blowing my mind.
你让我太惊讶了。
No, it's actually true.
不，这是真的。
Could we just talk hard numbers?
我们可以谈谈硬数据吗？
OK, sure.
好的，当然。
Do you have a bar graph that you could hold up to the microphone or something?
你有没有柱状图可以对着麦克风展示一下之类的？
Yes, I can describe it to you. What we did is-- it's just a graph. So I took the baseline-- a normal week, before we started the experiment, of fighting. But I didn't do all the fighting, because that's all I would have categorized. All day, I would have sat there checking off things. So I checked the number of times I had to intervene. In a normal week, I charted 31.
是的，我可以描述给你听。我们做的是——这只是一个图表。我取了基准线——实验开始前一周的正常打架次数。但我没有记录所有的打架，因为那会是我整天唯一做的事。我会坐在那一直打勾。所以我记录的是我必须介入的次数。在正常的一周里，我记录了31次。
Per day or per week?
是每天还是每周？
Per week.
每周。
OK, and so now, after four weeks?
好的，那么现在，四周之后呢？
By week four, we're down to 14.
到第四周，我们降到了14次。
A drop of 50%. Now, you made recordings of these days where they were playing, where you would just set the tape recorder down with the two of them as they played and you just would let it roll. And we have some of those recordings here. And here's a typical one. They start off OK.
下降了50%。你录下了她们一起玩的日子，你只是把录音机放在旁边，让她们玩，让录音带一直走。我们有一些录音。这是典型的例子。她们开始时还行。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
[模糊不清]
And then they start to fight.
然后她们开始打架。
Can I mine out?
“我可以把我的拿出来吗？”
No, you can't do that. That's cheating.
“不，你不能那样。那是作弊。”
I want to get mine out.
“我想把我的拿出来。”
Zadie, Zadie, wait, stop for a second, please.
“扎迪，扎迪，等等，停一下，拜托。”
And then Zadie howls.
然后扎迪开始号啕大哭。
Mom!
“妈妈！”
And then, in these early recordings, you step in, usually to Zadie's defense.
在这些早期的录音中，你介入了，通常是保护扎迪。
Kennedy? You're supposed to be playing together.
“肯尼迪？你们应该一起玩。”
And that was sort of what happened. I stepped in often. I mean, it got to a level where, rather than have them fight, I would just stop it. And I cut Zadie a tremendous amount of slack. So I could see how I fed into Kennedy's frustration and into Zadie's sense of entitlement. So in a way, I was setting up a dynamic that didn't allow them to sort it out. It's interesting, because I think the experiment-- I didn't expect the effect that it would have on me. It made me step back. It made me step back a lot.
确实发生了这种事。我经常介入。我的意思是，它达到了某种程度，与其让她们打架，我宁愿直接叫停。而且我对扎迪非常宽容。所以我能看出我是如何助长了肯尼迪的挫败感和扎迪的权利感的。所以从某种意义上说，我建立了一种不允许她们自行解决问题的动态。很有趣，因为我觉得这个实验——我没预料到它会对我产生的影响。它让我退后。让我退后了很多。
Yeah, I had to say, by the end of the taping-- because you keep taping the whole way through-- it totally changes. Here's a typical tape. What happens is that they're playing together, and they'll start to fight.
是的，我不得不说，到录音结束时——因为你一直在录——它完全变了。这是一段典型的录音。发生的情况是她们在一起玩，然后开始要打架。
Zadie, do you hear me.
“扎迪，你听到了吗？”
Yes.
“听到了。”
There's a recording of them playing Memory. And Zadie screams.
有一段她们玩“记忆游戏”的录音。扎迪尖叫起来。
No, I don't want to do that.
“不，我不想做那个。”
And then Kennedy just basically keeps the game going, and starts talking to her about who her friends are at school.
然后肯尼迪基本上让游戏继续下去，并开始和她聊她在学校有哪些朋友。
Are you making friends at your new school?
“你在新学校交到朋友了吗？”
Yes.
“交到了。”
What are their names?
“她们叫什么名字？”
Emma, Becca.
“艾玛，贝卡。”
And you never enter the room. And then Kennedy basically takes it by the reins. She keeps the game going, and she basically engages Zadie in conversation. And they start to talk like real sisters. And then Zadie wins.
你从未进入房间。肯尼迪基本上掌控了全局。她让游戏继续，并把扎迪带入了谈话。她们开始像真正的姐妹一样交流。然后扎迪赢了。
Look, you won.
“看，你赢了。”
Mama, I won.
“妈妈，我赢了！”
And that interaction wouldn't have occurred had I jumped in, which I probably would have done two or three weeks prior. So, by the end of it, it was like, you know what, back off and just leave it alone.
如果我冲进去的话，那种互动就不会发生了，而在两三周前我可能就会那么做。所以到最后，就像是，你知道吗，退后，让它自己发展。
So when you started, you were saying this was going to be an experiment that was secretly on the two of them. But Kennedy thought it was just on Zadie. But in fact, it turns out that the secret is that it was actually an experiment on your behavior.
所以当你开始时，你说这是一场秘密针对她们两人的实验。但肯尼迪以为只是针对扎迪。但实际上，原来这秘密其实是对你行为的实验。
Exactly. And that my behaviors probably needed more modifications than Kennedy's. But yeah, I wouldn't have thought that a shift in my behavior would have the impact that it had.
没错。而且我的行为可能比肯尼迪的更需要矫正。但确实，我没想到我行为的转变会有这样的影响。
Now, this thing has totally changed your expectations and your picture of them.
现在，这件事完全改变了你的期望以及你对她们的看法。
In some ways, yeah. I'm loathe to admit it. I think my overriding angst or questions over whether they would be friends, and whether the fighting meant something-- and I realized, that's not what being siblings is. It's so complex. Zadie will say, straight out, I don't like Kennedy. I don't want to play with her, and at the same time, be absolutely worried about what's happening to her sister. And I realized those two coexist.
在某些方面，是的。我不愿承认。我想我对于她们是否能成为朋友、打架是否意味着什么的压倒性的焦虑和疑问——我意识到，那不是兄弟姐妹的意义。这太复杂了。扎迪会直说：“我不喜欢肯尼迪。我不想跟她玩。”同时又对姐姐身上发生的事情无比担心。我意识到这两者是并存的。
And I don't have that. There's nobody I have a love-hate relationship like that with. And I don't get it. And I'm prepared not to get it. I'm prepared to leave it alone and let it be, and realize, on some base level, they're connected. I don't see the connection quite yet, in some ways, and that's OK. I can trust it, whereas before-- I guess that's the big difference for me. Before I didn't really trust it.
但我没有那种经历。我跟任何人都没有那种又爱又恨的关系。我不明白。我准备好不去理解它了。我准备好随它去，顺其自然，并意识到在某种基础上，她们是相连的。我还没完全看清这种连接，在某种程度上，没关系。我可以信任它，而以前——我想这就是对我来说最大的不同。以前我并不真正信任它。
And so, how many weeks has it been since you actually stopped the experiment?
那么，自从你真正结束实验已经过去几周了？
It's been a couple, a week and a bit, like two weeks.
已经过了几周了，一周多，差不多两周。
And so, what's going to happen? Is Kennedy going to keep playing with her?
那么，接下来会发生什么？肯尼迪会继续跟她玩吗？
Who knows? I don't know. I would love to think yes. I don't know. It doesn't seem like it. It's certainly not the first thing on her mind when she comes home from school. It's not like Zadie's endeared herself to Kennedy through the four weeks. That certainly hasn't happened. I think she engages her a bit more, actually. So in terms of actually talking to her about, What was school like? What did you do? There were a couple of times where Zadie got quite upset over-- she got in trouble for going into Kennedy's room. And I got very upset with Zadie and made her sit on the stairs. And she ended up crying and Kennedy went and consoled her. That's the first time that's ever happened.
谁知道呢？我不确定。我真希望是肯定的。我不知道。看起来不像。当她从学校回家时，这肯定不是她首先想到的事。扎迪并没有在这四周里因为这个就变得让肯尼迪特别喜爱。那当然没发生。我觉得她实际上确实更多地参与了她的活动。所以谈到“学校怎么样？你做了什么？”时。有几次扎迪因为乱进肯尼迪的房间惹了麻烦而变得非常心烦。我当时对扎迪很生气，让她坐在楼梯上。她最后哭了，肯尼迪竟然过去安慰她。那是第一次发生这种情况。
It's made everything so much easier, like being a sister easier. But I can't imagine Zadie and I singing together. I just-- yeah.
这让一切都简单多了，比如当个姐姐变得容易了。但我无法想象扎迪和我一起唱歌。我只是——是的。
This, of course, is Kennedy, age 12.
这是肯尼迪，12岁。
So, Kennedy, did it work? Did the experiment work?
那么，肯尼迪，有效吗？实验成功了吗？
Yeah.
有效。
It did?
真的吗？
It did. She's considerably nicer and easier to be around.
是的。她好多了，相处起来容易多了。
Do you like her more?
你更喜欢她了吗？
Yeah, I do. I do like her more. She's easier to be around. I feel like I can really connect with her now, which is good.
是的，我更喜欢她了。她好相处了。我觉得我现在可以真正地与她产生联结，这很好。
Is she less annoying?
她没那么烦人了吗？
No, we have to work on that. We'll have to device a whole new experiment to get her to be less annoying.
不，我们得在这方面努力。我们得想出一个全新的实验来让她没那么烦人。
Really?
真的吗？
Yep.
是的。
And just, realistically, do you really think you're going to be able to keep it up?
那么，现实地讲，你真的觉得你能坚持下去吗？
I'm going to try. Maybe I can get my mom to still give me-- increase my allowance, maybe, if I keep it up.
我会尝试的。也许我能让我妈妈继续给我——增加我的零花钱，也许，如果我继续坚持的话。
I don't know. I actually don't think it's right for somebody to keep paying you to be with your sister. It'd almost be like if you found out like somebody was paying your mom to be nice to you. It would break your heart.
我不知道。我其实觉得让别人继续付钱让你陪妹妹玩是不对的。这就像如果你发现有人在付钱让你妈妈对你好一样。这会让你心碎的。
It would.
确实会。
And that's sort of what it would be like, if your sister would ever find out. Like, oh, there were five years where actually you were taking money in order to be nice to her. It would be the worst thing that she would ever hear.
如果你的妹妹发现的话，那基本上就是那种感觉。就像，噢，有五年时间你其实是在拿钱来对她好。那将是她听到的最糟糕的事情。
Yeah, I see. In that case, yeah, I'm going to stop, But yeah, it's a constant struggle.
是的，我明白了。如果是那样的话，是的，我会停止。但确实，这是一种持续的斗争。
So, what's going to happen? Because it's hard to figure out games that you can keep playing with her.
那么，接下来会发生什么？因为找出能继续跟她玩的游戏很难。
Yeah, it's really hard. Because, like, Memory, I'm beyond that. I think we can safely say that.
是啊，真的很难。因为，比如像“记忆游戏”，我已经玩腻了。我想我们可以肯定地说。
You can find the two kittens without a lot of trouble.
你可以毫不费力地找到两只小猫。
Pretty easily.
很容易。
Do you get anything at all from playing with her?
陪她玩，你还能得到什么其他东西吗？
Yeah, $25 a week. Yes. I get paid.
我可以说是得到了情感上的满足，但其实并没有。
And if you're not getting paid, do you get anything else from playing with her?
你能想象你们有一天会成为朋友吗？
I could say that I get a sense of emotional fulfillment, but not really.
算吧。现在要想象我们互相邀请对方去吃晚饭真的很难。
Can you imagine you guys are going to be friends someday?
我的意思是，看在上帝的份上，她甚至还没学会认字？
Sort of. Right now, it's pretty hard to imagine us inviting each other over to dinner.
我知道。
I mean, she can't even read, for God's sake?
那么，你向其他家庭推荐这个吗？
I know.
我真心推荐。
So, do you recommend this for other families?
你推荐？让他们去贿赂一个孩子，而且应该是大孩子？
I really do.
是的，对于那些孩子总是打架的家庭来说，这是一个好主意。我们可以申请专利，然后写出图表，把它卖掉。
You do? That they should bribe one kid, and that it should be the older kid?
那是肯尼迪，12岁。
Yeah, for the people with kids who are constantly fighting, this is a good idea. We could patent it and then write up charts and sell it.
[音乐 - 莫妮·洛的《It's a Shame》]
That's Kennedy, age 12.
接下来，大卫·塞达里斯将带来一个关于大卫与歌利亚的故事，我们相信你们可能会站到——嗯，那会是歌利亚那一侧。广告后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续进行。
[MUSIC - "IT'S A SHAME" BY MONIE LOVE]
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是“大卫与歌利亚”，讲述人们为试图平衡双方力量、给小人物一个机会而采取非凡举措的故事。我们已经进入节目的第二幕。
Coming up, David Sedaris finds a David and Goliath story where we believe that you will probably side with-- well, that would be Goliath. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
第二幕，遥远的工厂梦。如果一场大卫与歌利亚之间的战斗，对大卫来说意义重大，而对歌利亚来说毫无影响，会怎样？也许歌利亚甚至都没露面。来自柬埔寨，瑞秋·路易丝·斯奈德讲述了这个关于当地服装业的故事。我们两年前第一次播出它，那是所有相关人员的关键转折点。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, David and Goliath, stories of people doing extraordinary things to try to even things out between the two sides, give the little guy a shot. We've arrived at Act Two of our show.
服装业占柬埔寨出口的90%，所以当商业部长访问工厂时，他受到了像电影明星一样的欢迎。数百名工人，全是女性，穿着传统的柬埔寨深红配金色的丝绸礼服站在工厂车道两旁，挥舞着数百面柬埔寨国旗。她们向部长献上鲜花和水果。当他走进工厂的每个部门时，工人们从岗位上站起来欢呼。
Act Two, Dreams of Distant Factories. What if there were a battle between David and Goliath that meant a great deal to David and nothing at all to Goliath? And maybe Goliath doesn't even show up. From Cambodia, Rachel Louise Snyder tells this story about the garment industry there. We first put this on the air two years ago, which was a crucial turning point for everybody involved.
有机玻璃柜挂在天花板上，展示着她们制作的产品。抓绒运动衫、棉毯、法兰绒睡衣。部长占·普拉西斯对睡衣特别感到高兴。
The garment industry is 90% of Cambodia's exports, so when the minister of commerce visits a factory, he's greeted like a movie star. Hundreds of workers, all of them women, stand along the factory driveway in traditional Cambodian silk dresses in maroon and gold, waving hundreds of Cambodian flags. They offer the minister flowers and fruit. As he walks through each section of the factory, workers stand up from their stations and cheer.
“我们感到非常自豪的一件事是，有一年柬埔寨在女性睡衣方面的排名位居第一——”
Plexiglass cases hang from the ceilings and show the kinds of things they make. Fleece sweatshirts, cotton blankets, flannel pajamas. The minister, Cham Prasidh, is particularly happy about the pajamas.
女性睡衣？
There is one thing that we feel very proud, is that there is one year when Cambodia was ranking number one, in terms of pajamas, women's pajamas, for--
“是的。那是2000万美国女性穿着柬埔寨制造的睡衣的时候。我们在美国排名第一。睡得安稳，做着美梦。我们希望这能让大家想到是柬埔寨人在为她们生产这些睡衣。”
Women's pajamas?
当然，她们并没有想到。这就是柬埔寨问题的核心所在。服装业以大多数美国人无法想象、且一无所知的方式改变了柬埔寨。在20世纪70年代，柬埔寨内战中死亡人数在100万到200万之间，约占全国人口的三分之一。红色高棉消灭了各种形式的商业，甚至连货币本身也被废除。中产阶级被屠杀。在此后的二十年里，该国的经济陷入停滞，长期的干旱影响了数十万家庭。
Yes. That's when 20 million American women are wearing Cambodian pajamas. And we are ranking number one for that in the US. Sleeping soundly and having sweet dreams. We hope they would have us all thinking of Cambodians who are producing these for them.
但在90年代中期，外国投资者开始开设服装工厂，五年内，服装成为该国最大的出口产品。两件事使之成为可能。第一，几十年前实施的国际配额体系防止任何国家成为美国和欧洲市场唯一的服装供应商。这意味着超过50个国家有机会进入这个行业。
They're not, of course. And that's Cambodia's entire problem in a nutshell. The clothing business has transformed Cambodia in a way most Americans can't imagine and know absolutely nothing about. In the 1970s, between one million and two million Cambodians died, about a third of the population, in the country's civil war. The Khmer Rouge eliminated business of every kind, and even money itself. The middle class was slaughtered. For two decades after that, the country's economy was flattened, and chronic drought affected hundreds of thousands of families.
第二件事是，在克林顿政府领导下，柬埔寨参与了一场非凡的实验。它获得了进入美国市场的特殊准入，以交换良好的工人条件和国际劳工组织的工厂监测。柬埔寨不仅规定童工和血汗工厂为非法，还通过了世界上最进步的劳动法之一。八小时工作制、加班费、三个月产假、43天假期、年度健康检查，以及现场免费诊所。柬埔寨获得的进入美国和欧洲市场的渠道使该行业爆炸式增长，在短短10年内从无到有发展到了250家工厂。实验取得了巨大成功。
But in the mid-'90s, outside investors began opening garment factories, and within five years, clothes were the country's biggest export. Two things made this possible. First, an international quota system implemented decades ago kept any one country from being the sole provider of clothes to the American and European markets. That meant more than 50 countries got a shot at the industry.
但自2005年1月1日起，两项贸易协议——配额体系和与美国的协议——都结束了，这使柬埔寨处于一种尴尬的境地。它是世界上唯一一个同意所有这些严格劳动法的贫困国家。留给自由市场，它将不得不与泰国和越南等邻国以及中国和印度等工业巨头竞争。因此，摆在柬埔寨面前的问题是：一个贫穷的国家如果公平对待工人，还能生存下去吗？部长和任何人一样敏锐地看到了危险。
The second thing was that, under the Clinton administration, Cambodia was part of an extraordinary experiment. It got special access to US markets in exchange for good conditions for workers and factory monitoring by the International Labor Organization. The Cambodians didn't just make child labor and sweatshops illegal. They adopted some of the most progressive labor laws in the world. Eight-hour work days, paid overtime, three months' maternity leave, 43 days' vacation, annual health checkups, and free health clinics on site. The access Cambodia got to US and European markets made the industry explode, growing from nothing to 250 factories in just 10 years. The experiment was a huge success.
“因为我们目前只在服装领域取得了成功，而且还没能实现多元化，这就像一颗定时炸弹。如果你不能拆除这颗炸弹，未来可能会爆炸。如果服装业在柬埔寨不能生存，我们将面临社会危机。从农村来到工厂工作的女孩们，如果失去工作，她们将永远不会回到村里。你知道她们的命运会是什么。我不想细说。”
But as of January 1, 2005, both trade deals-- the quota system and the agreement with the Americans-- ended, and that's left Cambodia in a strange situation. It's the only poor country in the world that's agreed to all these strict labor laws. Left to the free market, it'll have to compete with neighbours like Thailand and Vietnam and industry mammoths like China and India. And so, the question facing Cambodia is, can a poor country survive if it treats its workers fairly? The minister sees the dangers as keenly as anyone.
他不想细说的是，其中一些女性可能会被迫卖淫。在金边周边，有超过25万名女性在服装厂工作。她们反过来支持着整个家庭，通常是在她们来的村子里。最低月工资为45美元，加上加班费，大多数工人的月收入为70美元。这比当地警察或教师的收入高出两到三倍。服装工人们供弟弟和孩子们上学，并补贴那些几乎无法维持的农场。
Because we were successful only in the garment sector so far, and we have not been able to diversify a lot, it's a kind of time bomb. And if you cannot defuse this time bomb, you're going to maybe explode in the future. If the garment sector does not survive in Cambodia, we are going to have a social crisis in Cambodia. Girls who came from the countryside to work in factories, if they lose their jobs, they would never return to their village. And you know what would be their fate. I don't want to elaborate on that.
好消息是，到目前为止，即使贸易协议已到期，她们还是设法维持了下来。最大的买家没有一个离开，出口甚至还增长了一些，比去年增长了7%。尽管在过去几年，增长率更接近20%。
What he doesn't want to elaborate on is that some of these women might turn to prostitution. Over a quarter million women work in the garment factories around Phnom Penh. They, in turn, support their entire families, often back in whatever village they came from. Minimum monthly wage is $45, and with overtime, most workers make $70 a month. That's two and three times what a police officer or teacher makes here. Garment workers send their brothers and their children to school, and subsidize farms that barely survive.
但自1月1日所有贸易保护终结以来，柬埔寨的工厂突然被客户要求降低成本和价格。一些工厂已经关闭。数千人失业。工人加班减少，管理层也感到紧缩。
The good news is, so far, even with the trade deals expired, they've managed to stay afloat. None of the biggest buyers have left, and exports have even grown a little, 7% compared to last year. Though, in previous years, growth was more like 20%.
“这真的很令人担心。我们的成本其实非常高。”
But since January 1, and the end of all their trade protections, Cambodian factories suddenly are being asked by their customers to lower costs and prices. Some factories have closed. Thousands of people have lost their jobs. Workers are getting less overtime and management is feeling the pinch.
沃伦·范在金边郊区经营着一家拥有800名工人的相对较小的工厂。他们主要生产李维斯牛仔裤。听沃伦说，生意很差。在柬埔寨制造服装比大多数国家都要昂贵。柬埔寨不生产所需的任何原材料，所以要制造一条牛仔裤，沃伦不仅要进口布料，还要进口线、拉链、纽扣、铆钉，所有东西。还有公用事业。沃伦说最近的一项研究发现，柬埔寨的电费和东京市中心的电费一样高。而且还有劳工合规性，这极其昂贵。
It's actually very worrying. Our cost is actually very high.
“举个例子，我每月支付的电费大约是6000美元。现在，如果我不理会合规性，我可以关掉灯，让工人们在更暗的光线下缝纫。我可能可以节省20%。那是一大笔钱。这只是谈电费。饮用水呢？如果我不给工人们提供适当的饮用水，我每月可以节省600美元。如果我雇佣，比如，16岁以下的孩子，我甚至不需要给他们任何东西。我只需要给他们一碗米饭，他们就会为我工作。但当然，我不应该那样做。那是不对的。”
Voren Van runs a relatively small factory of 800 workers on the edge of Phnom Penh. They mostly make Levi's jeans. To hear Voren tell it, business is bad. Making clothes is more expensive in Cambodia than in most countries. Cambodia doesn't manufacture any of the materials it needs, so to create a pair of jeans, Voren has to import not only the fabric, but the thread, the zippers, the buttons, the rivets, everything. Then there's utilities. Voren says a recent study found that the cost of electricity is the same in Cambodia as it is in downtown Tokyo. And there's labor compliance, which is hugely expensive.
需要说明的是，沃伦的工厂以拥有当地最好的工作条件而闻名。他相信公平劳动法，相信这些法律最终会通过将农民转变为受过教育的中产阶级来改变社会和国家。但做正确的事，不调暗灯光，意味着沃伦只能勉强维持。而且他不是唯一一个。危险在于工厂会搬走，搬到越南等地。沃伦说这很容易。你所要做的就是租个地方，把机器运过去，雇些工人。两个月内就能运作。
Just to give you an example, the cost of electricity that I'm paying every month is about $6,000. Now, if I do not bother about compliance, I will switch off the lights and my workers can sew in a dimmer light. And I can save maybe 20%. And that's a lot of money. And you're just talking about electricity. How about drinking water? If I don't give my workers proper drinking water, I can save $600 every month. If I employ, for example, kids under 16, I don't even have to give them anything. I just have to give them a bowl of rice and they will work for me. But, of course, I shouldn't do that. It's not right.
“我可以说，这里的70%的工厂都在挣扎。我不认为我们中任何人在赚钱。我认为这只是为了维持这里的劳动力。”
To be clear, Voren's factory has a reputation for some of the best working conditions around. He believes in fair labor laws, that they're eventually going to transform society and the country by turning peasant farmers into an educated middle class. But doing the right thing, not dimming the lights, means Voren's only scratching by. And he's not the only one. The danger is that factories will pick up and move somewhere, like Vietnam. Voren says it's pretty easy. All you have to do is rent a space, ship your machines, and hire some workers. You can be running in two months.
你只是在生存。
I can say that 70% of the factories here are struggling. I don't think any of us are making money. I think it's just to maintain the workforce here.
“只是生存，是的。不仅是生存。我知道很多工厂状况都不好。它们随时可能倒闭。如果我能提前三个月规划，有确认的订单，我就认为自己很安全。情况现在非常糟糕。目前的情况是我甚至无法规划超过两周。所以我不知道该怎么办。”
You're just surviving.
你怎么获得订单？
Just surviving, yes. And not only surviving. I know a lot of factories are not doing very well. They may close down any day. If I can plan three months ahead, with confirmed order, I consider myself very safe. The situation is very bad now. The situation right now is that I cannot even plan for more than two weeks. So I do not know what to do.
冷不防的推销电话。
How do you get orders?
你打冷不防的推销电话？
Cold calls.
“噢，是的，我们给每个人都打推销电话。”
You cold-call?
你亲自打推销电话？
Oh, yes, we cold-call everyone.
“噢，是的。不只是我。每次我给更大的工厂打电话，他们就会说类似的话，‘噢，范先生，我很抱歉。今天，您是第六个打电话给我要订单的人了。’”
But you personally cold-call?
这怎么——我无法想象处于那种压力下。我觉得我会得溃疡，而且会整夜睡不着觉。
Oh, yes. And not only me. Every time I call a bigger factory, they will say something like, Oh, Mr. Van, I'm so sorry. Today, you are the sixth person that calls me to ask me for orders.
“多谢上帝我有个善解人意的妻子。我变瘦了，但那是工作的一部分。我认为外面的每个人，如果你看到他们——如果你看到工厂经理们，我觉得他们现在比以前瘦多了。”
How does it-- I cannot imagine being under that kind of stress. I just think I would have ulcers, and I would be awake all the time.
[笑声]
Thank goodness I have an understanding wife. I'm getting thinner, but that's part of the job. I think everybody outside, if you see them-- if you see factory managers, I think they're now a lot thinner than they were.
一天下午，我和翻译去了金边的一个主要制造业区，一个叫[模糊不清]的街区，我以前去过很多次。那是进城的主干道，两旁挤满了为工厂工人提供食品摊位和其他小贩。
[LAUGHTER]
这个区域有趣的地方在于，我第一次来到这里快两年了，当时它还是个繁荣的区域。当时有成千上万的人出来，这里一直很活跃。它本来很热闹、很吵，现在大家都坐在那里。这甚至还不是热季。以前我来这里时，有时甚至繁忙到走路比车流移动还快。现在它看起来真像是一条高速公路。
One afternoon, I go with a translator to one of the main manufacturing areas of Phnom Penh, a neighborhood called [UNINTELLIGIBLE], where I've been many times before. It's the main route out of town, and it's lined with food stalls and other vendors that cater to factory workers.
我们看到一个女人正在把猪肉和牛肉切成细条。我问她为什么肉块这么小。
The thing that's interesting about this area is that I first came here close to two years ago now, and it was a thriving area. There were just thousands and thousands of people out, and constant activity here. It was just so lively and so noisy and everyone's just sitting around now. It's not even hot season. Sometimes when I would come down here before, it would be so busy that you could walk faster than the traffic moved. And now it does seem like a highway.
“通常，服装工人买不了太多，所以她必须把肉切成小块，每块只有一克重。”
We see a woman slicing pork and beef into tiny strips. I ask her why the pieces are so small.
一克？她们买一克？
Normally, the garment worker, they don't buy a lot, so she has to cut the small pieces, which weigh only one gram.
“是的。很多人买一克猪肉。”
One gram? They buy one gram?
[讲高棉语]
Yes. A lot of people buy one gram of pork.
她说，以前人们挣得多，现在由于某种原因挣得少了。她不知道原因，但确实少了。过去六个月情况一直很糟，而且还在持续下滑。
[SPEAKING KHMER]
这里有个卖鞋的。我以前没见过。卖人字拖。这里有一双芭比人字拖，棕榈树人字拖。生意怎么样？
She said, before people made more money, and now people make less money for some reason. She don't know, but they just make less. It's been bad for the last six months, and it keeps going down.
[讲高棉语]
Here's a shoe salesman. I haven't seen this before. Selling flip-flops. Here's a pair of Barbie flip-flops, palm tree flip-flops. How's business?
[SPEAKING KHMER]
不太好。
所以有没有一双鞋都没卖出去的日子？
Not so much.
[讲高棉语]
So are there days where she doesn't even sell one single pair of shoes?
她说，说到那个，几乎每天都没卖出去。
[SPEAKING KHMER]
几乎每天？
She said to talk about that, almost every day, I don't sell.
[讲高棉语]
Almost every day?
她说：“我以前卖得很好。但这些天，生意不好做。我不知道为什么。我纳闷为什么最近生意不好。我真的不明白，因为我以前每个月靠卖这些旧货能赚300到400美元——赊账给工人们。她们发工资时会付钱。比如昨天，工人们发了工资，但我一双鞋都没卖出去。昨天是她们的发薪日。”
[SPEAKING KHMER]
自从贸易协议到期，柬埔寨必须为新业务奔波，因为现在它必须以一种新的方式与这么多国家竞争。这就是苏恩·范登场的地方，他是沃伦的兄弟，也是沃伦管理的工厂的老板。他也是服装制造商协会的负责人。
She said, "I used to sell a lot before. But these days, I don't do good business. I don't know why. I wonder why I don't make good business these days. I really don't get it because I used to make about $300, $400 a month by selling these old-- credit it to workers. And they pay when they get paid. Like yesterday, they-- worker got paid, but I didn't sell any pairs of shoes. And yesterday was their payday.
一天早上，我们在金边的一家酒店喝咖啡，就在一个恶劣的工厂老板卷款跑路、没有支付近1000名工人工资的两天后。范先生正在愤怒地发短信，安排出售公司的资产，主要是缝纫机和椅子，以尽可能地弥补欠薪。
Since the trade deals expired, Cambodia's had to hustle for new business, now that it's competing in a new way against so many countries. This is where Souieng Van comes in, Voren's brother and the owner of the factory Voren manages. He's also the head of the Garment Manufacturers Association.
“我觉得我有义务这样做，因为工厂倒闭是很糟糕的事。这就像小偷逃跑。他们甚至不管工人的工资。但在各地，在所有资本主义国家，甚至在美国，都有这种情况。但在美国或其他国家，公民有钱维持生存几周、几个月。在柬埔寨，她们没有工资甚至无法生存超过7到10天。所以她们饿着肚子。她们在挨饿。”
One morning, we meet for coffee at a hotel in Phnom Penh, just two days after a smarmy factory owner skipped town and blew off paying nearly 1,000 workers. Mr. Van was furiously text messaging, arranging to sell the company's assets, mostly sewing machines and chairs, to cover as much as he could of the lost wages.
范先生来自一个有权势的家庭，家境富裕到从法国进口了一个马厩的马。他可以做任何事情。但他恰好相信柬埔寨正在努力做的事情，并认为拯救服装业是他的职责。为了做到这一点，他的日子里塞满了会议，经常有工厂协会秘书长肯·卢在旁协助。
I feel I have a duty to do it, because the factory closed is a bad one. It is like a thief running away. And they don't even take care of the wages. But it's in everywhere, in all capitalists countries, even in the States. But in America, in other countries, citizens have money to survive for a few weeks, a few months. In Cambodia, they cannot survive without their wages for over seven days, 10 days. So they are hungry. They're hungry.
“那么，早上好，女士们、先生们。”
Mr. Van comes from a powerful family, and has the kind of money where he's imported a stable full of horses from France. He could be doing anything. But he happens to believe in what Cambodia's trying to do, and he considers it his duty to help save the garment industry. To do that, his days are crammed with meetings, often with the Factory Association's secretary general, Ken Loo, at his side.
他们正与两打穿着西装的新加坡男女坐在一张桌子旁。桌子中央的三个大托盘上放着热带水果和瓶装水。新加坡人都是制造协会的成员，他们正在进行考察，寻找可以开展业务的新国家。他们这次行程也去了越南，范先生和肯想尽一切办法说服他们柬埔寨是更好的选择。他们有两天时间。肯负责大部分谈话，他从柬埔寨的王牌开始，其实这是他们唯一能卖的东西。
So, good morning, lady and gentlemen.
“柬埔寨在许多国际买家中享有良好声誉，特别是那些关心企业形象、关心企业社会责任的大买家。盖璞（GAP）一直是我们要么是最大的单一买家。”
They're sitting at a table with two dozen Singaporean men and women in Western suits. Tropical fruit and bottles of water sit on three big trays in the middle of the table. The Singaporeans are all members of a manufacturing association, and they're on a fact-finding mission, looking for a new country where they can open up their businesses. They've also been to Vietnam on this trip, and Mr. Van and Ken want to do everything they can to persuade them Cambodia's the better choice. They have two days. Ken does most of the talking, and he starts with Cambodia's trump card, really the only thing they have to sell.
仅盖璞就在该国拥有40家工厂，占柬埔寨整个服装业的25%。许多其他大牌也在这里。坐在一间金边的瓷砖会议室里，外面是小贩推着面条车的嘈杂声，听着亚洲高管们背诵你在当地商场看到的每一个品牌名称，这感觉很奇怪。
Cambodia has a good reputation with many international buyers, especially the big buyers that are concerned about their corporate image, concerned about corporate social responsibilities. And GAP has been our largest single buyer.
“李维斯、H&M、耐克、阿迪达斯、锐步，都表示打算增加从柬埔寨的采购。当然，柬埔寨并不是生产的万灵药。我们有自己的内部问题，这些是世界上所有发展中经济体面临的问题，即腐败、官僚主义。”
The GAP alone has 40 factories in the country, and constitutes 25% of Cambodia's entire clothing industry. Lots of other big names are here, too. It's weird to be sitting in a tiled conference room in Phnom Penh while vendors push wooden noodle carts outside, and hearing Asian executives recite every brand name you'd see in your local mall.
柬埔寨人对在该国做生意的问题非常坦率。腐败是臭名昭著的，该地区几乎每个人，包括新加坡人，都知道这一点。假装不知道没多大意义。然后是工会。
Levi's, H&M, Nike, Adidas, Reebok, all have indicated their intention to increase sourcing from Cambodia. Of course, Cambodia is not a panacea for production. We have our own internal problems, and these are the problems faced by all developing economies in the world, namely corruption, bureaucracy.
“给你们个概念，目前我们有223家服装厂。根据最近统计，有785个工会。最近统计的数字，而且还在增长，还在增长。”
The Cambodians are amazingly frank about the problems of doing business in their country. The corruption is notorious, and pretty much everyone in the region, including the Singaporeans, knows it. And there's not much point pretending otherwise. Then there are the unions.
没错。平均每家工厂三个工会。有时一家工厂里的一群工人罢工，而其他人则在岗位上忙碌。这使得谈判极其笨拙。腐败的工会向工厂主和其他工人勒索钱财，并要求荒谬的福利。业主们已经觉得基于法国劳动法的许多规定是不公平的。
Just to give you an idea, we have, at present, 223 garment factories. And, at the last count, 785 unions. At last count, and growing, and growing.
例如，在与新加坡人的会议中，大量时间花在关于哺乳假的问题上，这是为新妈妈们规定的。新加坡人想知道：它们怎么实施？婴儿会带到工厂吗？在柬埔寨，职业女性把孩子留给家人照看，所以哺乳假简直是一场物流噩梦。有许多像这样的法律，这些头痛的事是公平劳动的成本。
That's right. An average of three unions per factory. Sometimes one group of workers in a factory will go on strike while the others work away at their posts. It makes negotiations totally unwieldy. Corrupt unions have extorted money from factory owners and other workers, and demanded ridiculous benefits. Owners already feel a number of the rules, based on French labor laws, are unfair.
但肯告诉他们，这些成本都是值得的，然后他告诉他们柬埔寨保持竞争力的新战略。这是一个提交给国会——美国国会——的法案，名为《2005年贸易法案》。如果通过，柬埔寨和一批其他贫困国家将获得免税进入美国市场的权利。目前，她们平均支付17%的关税。肯解释说，柬埔寨正在要求税收减免，与其他13个所谓的“最不发达国家”（LDCs）一起。他们包括斯里兰卡，希望那里的海啸能为该法案赢得一些同情票。肯和范先生将在未来一周飞往华盛顿游说该法案，肯列出了他们用来向美国议员们推销的论点。
In the meeting with the Singaporeans, for example, a lot of time was taken up with questions about breastfeeding breaks, which are required for new mothers. How do they happen? the Singaporeans wondered. Do the babies come to the factories? In Cambodia, working women leave their kids with family, so the breastfeeding thing is a logistical nightmare. There are a bunch of laws like this, headaches that are the cost of fair labor.
“切入点非常合乎逻辑。世界上有50个最不发达国家。美国已经为50个最不发达国家中的35个提供了优惠准入，基本上是在撒哈拉以南非洲地区、加勒比海地区和南美洲。但亚太地区的15个最不发达国家被遗漏了。我们正在接洽美国人，我们正在接洽政客们，说：看，你们遗漏了我们。我们不要求任何额外的东西。我们只是想被公平地视为最不发达国家。你们给了其他最不发达国家这种待遇。我们觉得你们给我们同样的待遇是公平的。”
But Ken tells them these costs will all be worth it, and then he tells them Cambodia's new strategy to keep the country competitive. It's a bill before Congress-- the US Congress-- called the Trade Act of 2005. If it passes, Cambodia and a bunch of other poor countries would get tariff-free access to the US market. Right now, they're paying an average of 17%. Ken explains that Cambodia is asking for the tax break along with 13 other so-called least developed countries, or LDCs. They included Sri Lanka, hoping the tsunami there would earn the bill some sympathy votes. Ken and Mr. Van will be flying out to Washington to lobby for the bill in a week, and Ken lays out the pitch they're using with the American lawmakers.
“我们得到了非常好的反应。一些政客感到非常惊讶。‘噢，真的吗？亚太地区的14个最不发达国家被遗漏了？’这包括几个在众议院有很多利益相关的国家，即阿富汗。我们有非常强大的两党支持者，意味着我们得到了共和党和民主党的支持。例如，我们刚刚有了——是谁？奥巴马？”
The angle is very logical. There are 50 LDCs in the world, five-zero. And the US has provided preferential access for 35 out of the 50 LDCs, basically in the sub-Saharan African region and the Caribbean and the South American. But 15 LDCs in the Asia-Pacific region have been left out. We are approaching the Americans, we are approaching the politicians, to say, Look, you have left us out. We are not asking for anything extra. We just want to be treated fairly as an LDC. You have given this to other LDCs. We feel it is fair you give the same treatment to us.
巴拉克·奥巴马。
And we have gotten very good reactions. Some of the politicians were very surprised. Oh, really? 14 LDCs in Asia-Pacific were left out? Which includes a couple of countries that have a lot of interest in the House, namely Afghanistan. We have got very strong bipartisan sponsors of the bill, meaning we have got Republican and Democrat sponsors. For example, we just had-- what's-- Obama?
“我们刚刚有巴拉克·奥巴马签署成为我们法案的共同发起人。巴拉克·奥巴马被视为美国年轻一代政客的领袖。我们也在努力说服克林顿参议员，因为有她的支持会非常有影响力，因为她代表了许多女性的声音。”
Barack Obama.
这就是对抗巨人的小人物的感觉。你必须了解关于巨人的一切，而巨人甚至不知道你在那儿。新加坡人询问有关该法案的细节，以及年底前通过的可能性。他们说国会的投票方式将左右他们的决定。会议休会。
We just had Barack Obama sign on as a co-sponsor for our bill. Barack Obama is seen as the leader of the young generation of politicians in the US. We are also in the process of convincing Senator Clinton, because having her on board would be very influential, because she represents a lot of the female voice.
范先生和肯没有告诉新加坡人的是，如果《贸易法案》不通过，而且如果不快点，到2005年底或2006年初，可能就太晚了。在范先生的工厂，沃伦说只要两个月没有订单，他的工厂和其他工厂就会倒闭。
This is what it's like to be the little guy up against the giant. You have to know everything about the giant, and the giant doesn't even know you're there. The Singaporeans ask for details about the bill, and the likelihood it will pass by the end of the year. They say the way Congress votes will sway their decision. The meeting adjourns.
7月，商业部长占·普拉西斯、范先生和肯飞往华盛顿特区游说《2005年贸易法案》。这次旅行是提前几个月计划好的，他们押注CAFTA（中美洲自由贸易协定）届时会解决。结果并没有。两天里，他们游说了任何愿意接见他们的国会议员，结果是八个人。当他们听到柬埔寨的故事时，大多表示同情，其中三人签署了法案。但肯说议员们被其他问题缠住了。
What Mr. Van and Ken didn't tell the Singaporeans is that if the Trade Act doesn't pass, and soon, by the end of 2005 or the first few months of 2006, it might be too late anyway. At Mr. Van's factory, Voren says all it would take is two months without orders, and his factory and others would close.
“他们当时都沉迷于CAFTA。当我们问他们是否准备好支持该法案时，他们说，‘目前不行。除非我们否决CAFTA或我们让CAFTA通过，否则该法案不会有进展。’所以这有点令人沮丧。”
In July, Commerce Minister Cham Prasidh, Mr. Van, and Ken flew to Washington, DC to lobby for the Trade Act of 2005. The trip had been planned months in advance, and they'd banked on the fact that CAFTA, the Central American Free Trade Agreement, would be resolved by then. It wasn't. For two days, they lobbied any member of Congress who would see them, which turned out to be eight people. Mostly, when they heard the Cambodian story, they were sympathetic, and three of them signed onto the bill. But Ken says the congressmen were preoccupied with other issues.
他们还希望与布什总统会面，或者至少是来自他政府的某个人。但总统也忙于CAFTA以及他的最高法院新提名人约翰·罗伯茨。他们之前的旅行也差不多。他们的法案只有25个支持者，远低于他们理想中的70个，尽管这已经远超任何人的预期了。
They were all obsessed with CAFTA at the moment. And when we asked them whether they were ready to support the bill, they said, Not at this moment. This bill is not going to move unless we defeat CAFTA or unless we get CAFTA approved. So that was a bit disheartening.
“我们交谈的每一个人都告诉我们：不可能。完全没机会。当我们与美国政府交谈时，当我们与美国大使馆交谈时，他们说，引用：‘完全没机会。你不可能得到它。’但我们仍然投入我们的资源，投入我们的时间为了这个事业。这确实是很多钱。”
They'd also hoped to meet with President Bush, or at least someone from his administration. But the president was also preoccupied with CAFTA, and with his new Supreme Court nominee, John Roberts. Their previous trips had gone about the same. Their bill only has 25 sponsors, short of the 70 they ideally want, though this is way further than anybody thought they'd get.
在柬埔寨，服装业每天都是头版新闻。工厂开工或倒闭。新品牌进来或离开。工人们罢工或失业。虽然这个法案对柬埔寨人意味着一切，但令人悲伤的事实是，美国人甚至不知道所有这些正在发生。这是商业部长占·普拉西斯。
Every single person we speak to tells us, Impossible. No chance in hell. When we speak to the US administration, when we speak to the US Embassy, they say, quote, "No chance in hell. You're not going to get it." But still, we commit our resources, we commit our time for this cause. And it's really a lot of money.
“其实，对我来说，当我走的时候，我有种像乞丐一样的感觉。但我必须去，尽管我觉得像个乞丐，因为在我身后，有250万人在指望这个《贸易法案》来生存。”
In Cambodia, the garment industry is front-page news every single day. Factories open or close. New brands come in or leave. Workers strike or lose their jobs. And while this bill means everything to the Cambodians, the sad fact is that Americans don't even know any of this is happening. Here's Commerce Minister Cham Prasidh.
你以为柬埔寨在这个法案上唯一自然的盟友应该是工会，他们总是试图让美国在其贸易法案中包含海外工人的权利。但事实上，柬埔寨《贸易法案》最直言不讳的反对者是一个工会，他们在华盛顿之行中最戏剧性的时刻是部长在卡内基国际和平基金会发表演讲时，纺织工会UNITE的首席经济学家马克·莱文森站起来与他争论。
Actually, for me, when I go, I have the feeling that I'm coming like a beggar. But I need to go, despite I feel like a beggar, because right behind me, I have 2 million and a half people who are counting on this Trade Act to survive.
莱文森说，自从美国与柬埔寨的贸易协议结束以来，工人的条件变得越来越糟。
You'd think the one natural ally Cambodia would have for this bill would be the labor unions, who are always trying to get the US to include workers' rights overseas in its trade bills. But, in fact, Cambodia's most vocal opponent of the Trade Act is a labor union, and the most dramatic moment of their trip to Washington came when the minister was speaking at the Carnegie Endowment for International Peace. And Mark Levinson, the chief economist for UNITE, the textile union, stood to argue with him.
“我们从柬埔寨工人那里听到的是，自从那个联系结束后，柬埔寨出现了倒退。柬埔寨的情况正在恶化，因为那个成功的实验现在已经结束了。”
Levinson said that since the US trade deal with Cambodia ended, workers' conditions have gotten progressively worse.
这就是他的出发点。尽管柬埔寨工人在工厂车间工作时的条件有所改善，但当工人们举行示威活动，即使是十几个人这样的小规模示威，警察也会来驱赶她们。工会组织者受到了恶棍的威胁、恐吓和殴打，试图压制异议。两年前，一位极受欢迎的工会领袖在周日早上读报纸时被枪杀。大多数人都认为这是政治谋杀。1.5万人参加了他的葬礼。
What we hear from workers in Cambodia is that since that link ended, there's backsliding in Cambodia. The situation is deteriorating in Cambodia, because the experiment, which was a success, is now over.
但当马克·莱文森提起这件事时，这彻底激怒了部长。从他的观点来看，像美国这样的老牌民主国家对像柬埔寨这样崭新的民主国家没有现实的期望。一个新国家不可能一下子解决所有的腐败和民权虐待问题。如果没有像这个贸易法案这样的帮助，只会使问题更难解决，而不是更容易。
Here's where he's coming from. Even though conditions have improved for Cambodian workers when they're on the job on the factory floor, when workers hold demonstrations, even small ones of a dozen people or so, police come and run them off. There have been threats, intimidation, and beatings of union organizers by thugs trying to repress dissent. Two years ago, a wildly popular union leader was gunned down on a Sunday morning while he was reading the newspaper. Most everyone believes it was a political killing. 15,000 people attended his funeral.
“你必须理解我们所处的环境。你知道柬埔寨的历史，但你并不是什么都知道。我们在30年内经历了六个连续的政治体制。像我这个年纪的人，我们向六种不同的柬埔寨国旗敬过礼。你到目前为止向多少个敬过礼？只有一个。通过这种冲突、种族灭绝和一切，我们走出来，试图先找到和平。”
But when Mark Levinson brings this up, it utterly galls the minister. From his point of view, established democracies like America don't have realistic expectations of brand-new democracies like Cambodia. A new country isn't going to solve all the corruption and civil rights abuses all at once. And without help like this trade bill, it'll just make the problems harder to solve, not easier.
“我们都是崭新的。六年前，柬埔寨几乎没有工会。工厂里没有工会，因为柬埔寨没有工厂。我们都是年轻的。工人们年轻，工会年轻，工厂[？在建设？]，工厂经理们是新的。我们有一个也是新的制度。我们对民主化持开放态度，但问题是我们需要一个过渡期，让人们在学习法律、遵守法律的过程中成熟起来。”
You have to understand the context in which we are living. You know the history of Cambodia, but you have not known everything. We have gone through six successive political regimes in Cambodia within 30 years. People of my age, we saluted six different national flags of Cambodia. How many have you saluted so far? Only one. And through this type of conflict, genocide, and everything, we come out and try to find peace first.
在离开华盛顿前，范先生和肯去了乔治敦的几家连锁店。他们来美国时从不错过这样的机会，去看看时尚的美国人购买的“柬埔寨制造”的衣服。他们的第一站是阿迪达斯。结果不太好。
We are all new. Six years ago, there is almost no unions in Cambodia. There are not unions in factories because there are no factories in Cambodia. We are all young. The workers are young, the unions are young, the factories [? are building, ?] the factory managers are new. And we have a system that is also new. We are open to democratization, but the question is that we need a kind of transition period where people mature in learning the laws, in abiding to the laws.
不，越南制造。泰国。印尼。土耳其。
Before they leave DC, Mr. Van and Ken check out a few chain stores in Georgetown. They never miss a chance to do this when they come to the States, to see the actual "Made in Cambodia" clothes that trendy Americans buy. Their first store is Adidas. It doesn't go that well.
同样的情况在GAP童装和Abercrombie & Fitch重复上演。在GAP，情况看起来更有希望。肯在桌子上发现了一些熟悉的衬衫，他发誓在柬埔寨见过这种条纹女士上衣。但当他们查看标签时，发现是斯里兰卡制造。他们不仅没找到柬埔寨产品，还发现了他们本可以在柬埔寨制造的东西，他们想要制造的东西。范先生似乎对该国缺乏代表性感到困惑。他拿起一件Baby GAP的微型卡其裤。
No, made in Vietnam. Thailand. Indonesia. Turkey.
“我们在柬埔寨可以做得更好。看看这个缝线。看，这很糟糕。她们没完成。我们可以做得更好。”
The same scenario is repeated at GAP Kids and at Abercrombie & Fitch. At The GAP, things seem more promising. Ken spots some familiar shirts on the table, striped ladies' tops he swears he's seen in Cambodia. But when they check the labels, they see Sri Lanka. Not only aren't they finding Cambodian products, they're finding stuff they could be making in Cambodia, stuff they want to be making. Mr. Van seems almost mystified by his country's lack of representation. He picks up a tiny pair of khaki pants at Baby GAP.
这种缝线会被质量控制部门拒绝。
We can do it better in Cambodia. Look at this stitch. Look, it's lousy. They're not finishing. We can do better.
“我们做得更好。这是Baby GAP在柬埔寨必须要做的事情。出了点问题。为什么Baby GAP不在柬埔寨生产？”
This stitch would be rejected by quality control.
不知道。好问题。
We do better. Something Baby GAP has to do in Cambodia. Something wrong. Why is Baby GAP not down in Cambodia?
为什么我们不能制造那个？
I don't know. Good question.
最后他们取得了一些成功。他们发现了一件售价50美元的蓝色足球衫。柬埔寨将获得大约10美元，或售价的五分之一。他们看到的其他少数柬埔寨制造的服装是简单的T恤或运动衫，没有更复杂的东西，比如能带来更高价格的装饰缝线，那是中国、越南和泰国制造的那些东西。总而言之，对他们来说非常令人沮丧。
Why can't we make that?
柬埔寨仍然是该行业中一个小而挣扎的参与者。在他们看来，公平劳工实践实验的成功或失败现在掌握在美国国会手中。但能够帮助柬埔寨的立法，《2005年贸易法案》，在2005年没有任何机会进入投票阶段。范先生、肯和部长并没有放弃。他们为10月份预定了另一次游说旅行，但因为卡特里娜飓风和丽塔飓风在最后一刻取消了。他们还没有重新安排时间。他们在等待美国政客们能给予他们更多关注的时候。很难想象那个时候会是什么时候。
Finally they have some success. They spot a blue soccer jersey costing $50. Cambodia will get roughly $10, or a fifth of the selling price. The few other Cambodian-made garments they see are simple t-shirts or sweat tops, nothing more complex, like ornamental stitching that commands higher prices, the kinds of things that China, Vietnam, and Thailand do. All in all, pretty discouraging for them.
瑞秋·路易丝·斯奈德住在柬埔寨。这个故事也出现在她刚出版的书《逃亡的牛仔布》中，讲述了全球经济中制造牛仔裤的人们。丽莎·波拉克在华盛顿特区为这个故事做了报道和录音。
Cambodia is still a small, struggling player in the industry. And the way they see it, the success or failure of their experiment at fair labor practices is now in the hands of the US Congress. But the legislation that could help Cambodia, the Trade Act of 2005, doesn't stand any chance at all to make it to a vote in 2005. Mr. Van and Ken and the minister aren't giving up. They had scheduled another lobbying trip for October, but it was canceled at the last minute because of Hurricanes Katrina and Rita. They haven't rescheduled yet. They're waiting for a time when US politicians can give them more attention. It's hard to imagine when that time will be.
距离我们首次播出那个故事已经两年了，柬埔寨人认为将拯救该国服装业的《2005年贸易法案》从未进入参议院讨论。今年它被重新提出，但目前正在委员会审议。虽然这个特定法案的未来仍然不确定，但美国对可以从中国进口的服装数量设定了限制。对中国的这些限制将持续到2008年。肯·卢说，如果这些限制解除，柬埔寨可能会损失四分之一的服装收入。
Rachael Louise Snyder lives in Cambodia. This story also appears in her just-published book, Fugitive Denim , about the people who make blue jeans in the global economy. Lisa Pollak did reporting and recording for this story in Washington, DC.
不过目前为止，柬埔寨人实际上做得还不错。尽管她们感到担心，但在2005年到2006年间，出口增长了近20%，并且此后一直保持增长，主要原因是像盖璞和李维斯这样的公司，因为柬埔寨的公平劳动行为而想要从那里采购。
It's been two years since we first broadcast that story, and the Trade Act of 2005, which Cambodians thought would save the clothing industry in their country, never got to the Senate floor. It was reintroduced this year, but is now currently sitting in committee. While the future of this particular act remains uncertain, the US has put limits on the amount of clothing that could be imported from China. Those limits on China will continue until 2008. Ken Loo says that Cambodia is likely to lose a fourth of their garment revenues if those limits are lifted.
柬埔寨继续向华盛顿特区派遣游说代表团，希望能通过某个版本的《贸易法案》，这样她们在中国的配额结束时就不会被压垮。
For now, though, the Cambodians have actually done pretty well. Despite their fears, exports were up nearly 20% between 2005 and 2006, and they've remained up ever since, mostly because of companies like The GAP and Levi's, who want to buy from Cambodia because of their fair labor practices.
[音乐 - 莫里西的《Such a Little Thing Makes Such a Big Difference》]
Cambodia continues to send their lobbying delegation to Washington, DC, hoping to get a version of the Trade Act passed, so they don't get creamed when Chinese quotas end.
第三幕，便便角历险记。好了，现在我们有了这个大卫与歌利亚的故事，其中的歌利亚是巨大的美国零售商，而大卫是普通人，非常特别的普通人。这是大卫·塞达里斯在路上时注意到的一种全国性现象。
[MUSIC - "SUCH A LITTLE THING MAKES SUCH A BIG DIFFERENCE" BY MORRISSEY]
图书巡演让你走遍全国，却几乎看不到什么。机场、酒店、主办你的书店，通常也就仅此而已。但你确实有机会认识人们，并享受那些你否则无法拥有的交流。就拿我在底特律外遇到的那个女人来说，我想是那里。我们聊了起来，在签书时，我得知她在塔吉特工作。
Act Three, Adventures at Poo Corner. Well, now we have this David and Goliath story, where the Goliaths are giant American retailers and the Davids are everyday people, a very particular kind of everyday people. This is a national phenomenon that David Sedaris noticed when he was out on the road.
“经常有人在你们店里排便吗？”我问道。
A book tour allows one to travel the country and see almost none of it. The airport, the hotel, the store that's hosting you, that's usually the extent of it. But you do get to meet people and enjoy the sorts of exchanges you probably couldn't otherwise. Take this woman I met outside of Detroit, I think it was. We got to talking, and while signing her book, I learned that she worked at Target.
她把手放在我的手上说：“你怎么知道？”
"Do a lot of people defecate in your store?" I asked.
“嗯，”我告诉她，“是这样的。”
And she placed her hand over mine, saying, "How did you know?"
在我男友休高中最后一年，他家搬回了美国，他在一家服装店找到了一份工作。好吧，那是盖璞。休在盖璞找到了一份工作。而且不止一次，有顾客进入试衣间并在地板上排便。准确地说是铺着地毯的地板。他大约六个月前提到过这个，我说：“我们在一起多久了？你现在才告诉我？”因为这种故事正是我的菜。到底是什么样的人会在盖璞排便？
"Well," I told her, "It's like this."
这可能被视为一种政治声明，或试图以某种方式报复，但这可能是抬举他们了。例外情况肯定存在，但据我了解，商店本身并不重要。在这个女人的塔吉特店里，人们会蹲在那些圆形衣架中间，就在那里解决，没有任何门可以遮挡。在Pier 1，她们会靠在墙上，脱下裤子。据我所知，那个地方就是个厕所。西尔斯和彭尼百货也是如此。而且这种事情已经持续了很久。
In my boyfriend Hugh's last year of high school, his family moved back to the United States and he got a job at a certain clothing store. OK, it was The GAP. Hugh got a job at The GAP. And on more than one occasion, a customer entered the dressing room and defecated on the floor. The carpeted floor, to be exact. He mentioned this about six months ago, and I was like, "We've been together for how long? And you're only telling me this now?" Because this kind of story is right up my alley. What kind of a person would defecate in The GAP?
作为一名进行图书巡演的作者，我相信我有责任将相关信息从国家的这一部分传播到另一部分。每晚，我都谈到连锁店排便的主题，97%的听众会摇头说不。“你在跟我开玩笑吧，”他们会说，“我不相信。”另外3%会点头说是。这些就是从事零售业的人。
It could be seen as a political statement, or an attempt to even some sort of a score, but that's probably giving credit where it's not due. There are bound to be exceptions, but from what I've gathered, the store itself is unimportant. In this woman's Target, people will crouch down in the middle of those circular clothing racks, do it right there with no door to hide them. In Pier 1, they'll just lean against the wall and lower their pants. The place is an outhouse, from what I've heard. So are Sears and Penny's. And this sort of thing has been going on for ages.
我交谈过的一个男人在克罗格超市理货，发誓这种情况一直发生。“就我而言，主要是孩子，”他说，我在相当多的人那里听到过这种说法。有些可怜的四岁孩子要求去厕所，母亲会指向鞋类部门黑暗的角落或金枪鱼罐头金字塔。我猜她们想，因为是个孩子，所以不算数。但我的意思是，得了吧，当然算数。
As an author on book tour, I believe it's my duty to spread pertinent information from one part of the country to another. Night after night, I addressed the subject of chain store defecation, and 97% of the audience would shake their heads, no. "You're putting me on," they'd say. "I don't believe it." The other 3% would nod, yes. And these were the ones who worked in retail.
在芝加哥，我遇到了一位图书管理员，她用精心制作的纸板城堡装饰了她的儿童区，那是她手工制作并涂成石头样子。城堡搭好了，第二天，她在吊桥内发现了什么？一坨大便，就是那个。尽管在这种情况下，是一个青少年留下的，他在电梯里犯下类似的罪行后承认了。
One man that I spoke to stocks shelves at Kroger, and swore that it happens all the time. "In my case, it's mainly kids," he said, which is something I heard from quite a few people. Some poor four-year-old will ask to go to the bathroom, and the mother will point toward a dark corner of the shoe department or to a pyramid of canned pineapple. I guess they figure that, because it's a child, it doesn't really count. But I mean, come on, of course it counts.
这属于不同的类别，但在拉斯维加斯，我与一个赌场保安交谈，他告诉我人们非常不愿意离开最喜欢的角子机，以至于他们经常在裤子里排便。他命令他们离开，但他们非但没有羞愧地溜走，反而会闹事，或者大多数人会这样，说等他们该死地准备好时就会回到房间。真是厚颜无耻。我对休说：“你会预料到在骰子桌上有那种行为。但角子机？”
In Chicago, I met a librarian who decorated her children's department with an elaborate cardboard castle, something she'd crafted by hand and painted to look like stone. The castle went up, and come the second day, what did she find lying just inside the drawbridge? A turd, that's what. Though, in this case, it was left by a teenager, who confessed after committing a similar crime in the elevator.
随着我的巡演推进，故事变得更刻薄、更毫无意义。我听说有一个女人走进一家书店的洗手间，在大卷卫生纸的中心排便，这不是那种你能一次做对的事情。这需要一定程度的练习，但在哪练习呢？当她完成后，这个女人把纸卷放回了架子上，这很欠考虑，但不如那个在宿舍洗衣机里排便的大学生，或者我在熟食店听说在小便池排便的顾客，或者在一家曾经宏大的酒店的落地烟灰缸里排便的顾客欠考虑。
It's sort of a different category, but in Las Vegas, I spoke to a guy who worked for casino security that told me that people are so reluctant to leave a favorite slot machine that they'll often defecate in their pants. He orders them to leave, but instead of skulking out in shame, they'll put up a stink, or most of them will, saying they'll go back to their rooms when they're damn well ready. The nerve. I said to Hugh, "You'd expect that kind of behavior at the craps table. But slot machines?"
我猜这些案例大多与在世界上留下你的印记有关，这是我们所有人都在一定程度上共有的冲动。有些人志存高远，创造出持久的艺术作品，而另一些人——嗯，我有什么资格评判呢？作为一种自我表达形式，在洗衣机里排便介于在公交车窗上刻下名字和点燃垃圾桶之间。无论能获得什么样的名声，注定是私人的，且希望是短暂的。但这正是当你满足于“二号”时会得到的结果。
As my tour advanced, the stories got meaner and more senseless. I learned of a woman who'd entered the restroom of a bookstore and defecated into the center of the toilet paper roll, which is not one of those things you'd get right the first time. It would require a certain amount of practice, but practice where? When she had finished, the woman placed the roll back on its holder, which is inconsiderate, but not as inconsiderate as a college student who has taken to defecating into his dormitory's washing machines, the customer who defecates into the urinal of the delicatessen I heard about, or into the standing ashtrays of a once-grand hotel.
大卫·塞达里斯是最近出版的《Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim》一书的作者，也是《Children Playing Before a Statue of Hercules》一书的编辑。
I'm guessing that most of these cases have to do with leaving your mark on the world, an impulse we all share on one level or another. Some shoot high, creating lasting works of art, and others-- well, who am I to judge? As a form of self-expression, defecating into a washing machine falls somewhere between scratching your initials into a bus window and setting fire to a trash can. Whatever notoriety there is to be gained is destined to be private, and hopefully short-lived. But that's what you get when you settle for number two.
我们的节目今天由黛安·库克和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼格、艾米·奥利里和丽莎·波拉克参与。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。阿德里安娜·马修韦茨经营我们的网站。萨姆·霍尔格伦、克里斯·拉德、塞斯·林德和布鲁斯·华莱士提供了制作帮助。杰西卡·霍珀提供了音乐帮助。
David Sedaris is the author, most recently, of the book Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim , and editor of the book, Children Playing Before a Statue of Hercules.
我们的网站，您可以免费获取我们的每周播客，或免费收听我们的旧节目，www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
Our program was produced today by Diane Cook and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Amy O'Leary, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Sam Hallgren, Chris Ladd, Seth Lind, and Bruce Wallace. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
[资助名单]
Our website, where you can get our weekly podcasts free, or listen to our old shows for free, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他对与我们合作有这样的感受。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
“我可以说是得到了情感上的满足，但其实并没有。”
WBEZ management oversight for our show by Mr. Torey Malatia, who feels this way about working with us.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
I could say that I get a sense of emotional fulfillment, but not really.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周同一时间将为您带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。